the Joe Rogan experience that's why
that's why the positions that we're in
and media you have to be very
responsible with these positions Malcolm
X said that Malcolm X said the person
who control the media controlled the
monitor the masses so you have to be
very very responsible when you used to
get a lot of flack for putting on just
different voices that people who didn't
agree with yeah like why are you giving
these people a platform platform I'm
like yo everybody deserves to be heard
yeah I guess something I'm not everybody
but you just I want to know how people
think - I want to even if I don't agree
especially people you don't again the
conversation isn't a cosign and I think
that's what we we often mistake but when
this day and age - was especially on the
left as so many people are talking about
D platforming they want a deep platform
people I don't like they know I thought
I don't like that I could either I
thought people getting mad at levar ball
this week you know the saying of the
comments he made the molle on ESPN which
I didn't he said he just was like she
was like hey let's shift gears you can
shift gives me any time but we didn't he
said it just like that you should be
they didn't say you nitwit was a
placeholder right if she had said hey
let's switch it up he would say hey but
every people's like oh they need to stop
putting him on ESPN I'm like wait a
minute huh literally just last year
y'all was saying he was the drunk on
calit2 picnicking right
you love him I hate him he's good
entertainment with that now because he
said that you want to take them off and
I'm like we got to stop doing that
because guess what every single one of
us is going to say something that is
going to offend somebody at some point
yeah yeah that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't have a platform I'm not
calling for nobody to get killed but
also makes things fun when people say
stupid [ __ ] sometimes you know when
Steven Smith was going off about Andrew
he's winning the title hey it was like
butter bean this is a disgrace there was
man like the guy is speaking the way he
would speak if you were around him yeah
do you gotta appreciate that unless you
want everybody to be Ryan Seacrest you
should [ __ ] to preach not there's
anything wrong on Ryan Seacrest but you
should appreciate someone who's just
given you what they really think
yes why don't we do that's why he's so
popular yeah we pretend to hate it but
the reality is we're gonna keep
listening the secondly it's a ruse also
pay attention la-z-boy
that's some America feeds off a - what
the president yeah that's what the
Kardashians are still viable our cousins
are the first family okay every year
every year they find a new piece of
trauma no [ __ ] gets calm and cool the
show ends so they need a new piece of
drama oh you got cheese on this here
who's gonna have a baby you gonna you
gonna be the baby but whatever it is
every year hey you gonna chop your dick
off but you know I respect her for with
Kim she's getting people out of jail
she's going for it I can go back before
they I respect the Kardashians because
if we really really pay attention to the
Kardashians over the past ten years
first of all you got to put them up
there with some of the greatest
dynasties of all time this is Lakers
this is Patriot this is [ __ ] they've
made billions yes billions with a B so
yes so many social conversations have
started because of the Kardashians
you're talking about interracial
relationships you're talking about the
transgender thing you're talking about
jobs mental health with condoms yeah
plastic surgery they did change the
shape of American women they changed
absolutely they changed essences they
made that whole fat relocation thing
popular they suck it out of your waist
turn your waist in this little thing and
turn your ass into this ridiculous
platform for okay Kim Kim learn that
from black women though good people
forget but that's a pile of the women
that we you would look at someone who
really has it yeah it's different yeah
you will see a woman who has a big ass
naturally it looks like it belongs on
yes it's a different thing yeah yeah
yeah they have thick legs right they're
they're they're [ __ ] genetically
superior built like a turkey they built
sexy yeah Kim's inspiration you know
people don't remember Kim came up in the
black circuit right she did King
magazine and smooth that's right that's
right Wendy Williams radio show earlier
that's what I'm better I'm better when I
was doing radio a women he knew her
before she was ever on anything when she
was who's who's assistant some of this
to organize closets for Paris Hilton I
got an old picture like me and Kim from
like 2006 different yeah but I will say
she always had that vision she's to
always say I'm gonna do a Paris is doing
times 100 Wow she [ __ ] did it
the secret she used the secret
secret is black dick that's the secret
smoke a black [ __ ] that kicked her off
because it used to be the kiss of death
of a girl did porn that was the end
Lisa Anne yeah she was the one to break
that down well what's it to her jenna
jameson
I think jenna jameson was the first one
to become actually popular outside of
porn oh I thought you meant like the
first person to break like the racial
barrier employ yes you want the purpose
she was the first to break the racial
part but I mean doing porn periods oh
yeah that where you could be up where
you could be a celeb outside yeah you
talk about radio it's not too many
people that came up off the Liberty sex
tapes between that really popped off
yeah who made it office acts do you
remember when girls were jamming
obviously they were showing their [ __ ]
on purpose [ __ ] did you not know that
camera was down near your [ __ ] they set
that up that's a lot of confidence today
were climbing out of the cars showing
their [ __ ] huh not a lot of fingers
okay that girl that was hopping on a
cause and you could see her vagina sex
tapes is out here getting prisoners free
is doing that I don't give a [ __ ] yeah I
don't know the [ __ ] if she's best
friends with Donald Trump Yeah right if
you care about prison reform okay about
criminal justice reform yes you should
be happy that these people are getting
out yeah you're worried about oh she's
doing it in the White House with Donald
Trump the guy who just did 15 years
right
nothing cares what President let him out
and what she doesn't have to do this
right she could just be buying cars and
getting her nails done she's choosing to
spend her time to get these people that
are unjustly accused and and convicted
and get them released and that and Trump
but like him or not he's listening her
and he's helping her that but you know
why cuz he's a celebrity he understands
the yeah so you keep saying all these
politicians to talk to a celebrity yes
that [ __ ] goes over his hey you gotta
send another celebrity to get in his ear
yeah cuz he understand that type of line
he understands their power he
understands where their reach is he
knows that Kim K doing something is way
more valuable than some random
Democratic Congress person